don lemon
don lemon is very very upset about the
biggest story i can't this is the
longest we haven't talked about it in
any show in probably two weeks
the written house story you know where
all of the evidence is on the side of
kyle rittenhouse that young man in
kenosha wisconsin who shot the antifa
people who were trying to murder him
all of the evidence is on his side none
of the evidence is on the prosecution
side it seems like the case is falling
apart before our very eyes and don lemon
he's really upset about that he wants to
know what would happen
if kyle rittenhouse were a black kid
just want to leave people with a picture
here are you going imagine
if
kyle rittenhouse was an 18 or 17 year
old black kid well that's a different
issue with a gun talk about that right
how would people feel how would the
judge treat him how would pundits think
about this this case uh what about the
people on the right who are making kyle
rittenhouse out to be a choir boy
because he went across state lines
inserted himself into a situation where
he that he had nothing to do with was
carrying a gun that he wasn't supposed
to carry because it was he was too young
it was illegal for him to carry that gun
and he wanted to he wanted to do it
because he was cool or the black kid did
that killed two people and injured
another person how would america feel
about that
first of all the hypothetical what would
happen if a young black man let's say a
young black man in these very riots that
that kyle rittenhouse went to what would
happen if he had a gun or some weapon
and were committing violence how what
would happen then we know what would
happen then they'd get off the hook
that's what would happen that's what's
been happening
for
most of the people that were involved in
the blm riots last year
you saw it especially in in the bronx
and in manhattan
people pleading down having much more
serious charges now just be minor
trespassing or some some lower charge
what would happen if a young black man
were looting or robbing or mugging
people or killing people during the blm
riots what would happen nothing would
happen they'd they'd face very
lenient
prosecution and that and they would get
cover from the media who were saying
they were involved in anti-racist
protests which is not what happened but
let's let's take this further
let's not just compare things that
share some similarities let's say
that kyle rittenhouse himself were a
black guy so not a young black man
showing up to the blm side and
protesting for blm not a young man
showing up and joining antifa but a
young black man
showing up to his place of business with
an ar-15 he's clearly more conservative
he's there of a young black man who who
shoots some antifa people who are trying
to attack him
how would how would the right react
the right would love that guy
the right would defend that guy every
bit as much as they are kyle rittenhouse
and we all know it
one because the evidence would be on his
side
but two
because he the guy would be on our side
right right
of course
conservatives
love
black people who support conservatives
don't i thought the left was just
attacking us for that that we like
thomas soul too much or we like candace
owens too much are we like are we like
this woman who won in in virginia the
lieutenant governor of virginia win some
series remember there were all these
headlines white supremacists always
loved black conservatives oh yeah so
what would happen if the
if the
kyle rittenhouse case if that were a
young black guy well all those
conservatives who the left says are
white supremacist evil they would by
their own logic they would support him
right
right now it just so happens all the
evidence would be on his side too and it
just so happens that the right wingers
are not white supremacist evil whatever
nonsense
but i just think even on the point don
lemon's making he's not right
because
the thing that matters here is substance
as well as form okay for the left it's
it's just about form i guess
it's just about how someone looks the
kind of superficial similar what about
the substance what are these guys
fighting for it's a big difference if a
guy shows up to a blm rally
or an antifa rally with a gun
and starts aggressing on people
i'm going to have a very different view
of him than if someone shows up
to that same rally on the side of the
business owners on the side of the
civilians on the side of the
conservatives and is not addressing but
actually just defending himself i guess
they both in both cases they both look
like a guy with a gun
but what they are they're doing is very
very
different i'm glad you like that clip
stop what you're doing ring the bell and
subscribe we appreciate that uh but even
more importantly head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe type in the michael knowles
show subscribe leave a five star review
if you wouldn't mind it we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]